The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Last time I
told you about oncogenes.
Oncogenes-- we discussed the
fact that these were gain
of function mutations that
occur in cancer cells--
that occur in normal cells as
they develop into cancer cells,
and then occur in cancer cells.
And we discussed the fact that
these are dominant mutations.
And this was exemplified by the
Weinberg experiment in which he
transferred a dominant oncogene
into a "normal cell' and caused
that cell to become transformed
despite the fact that it had
normal copies of the
same gene in its genome--
definition of a
dominant mutation.
We also talked about
tumor suppressor genes.
And tumor suppressor
genes importantly,
carry within them loss
of function mutations
in the context of cancer.
Loss of function mutations,
as such, these mutations
are recessive mutations
at the cellular level.
It's necessary to inactivate
both copies of a tumor
suppressor gene in
order to give rise
to a cell that's lacking
that function altogether.
And that's a cell that is on its
way to becoming a cancer cell.
And these loss of function
mutations can be various.
You might find
nonsense mutations
in a tumor suppressor gene--
blocks the production
of the protein.
You might find a deletion.
It takes out the entire gene,
or a big portion of the gene.
You might find a frame
shift mutation-- again,
that blocks the ability to make
any protein, or much protein.
And I also told you about
chromosome loss events.
The loss of the
chromosome that carries
the normal copy of
the tumor suppressor
gene as a frequent second event
to lose the remaining wild type
copy of the gene.
OK, so this is just a
little bit of review.
Now, I framed the discussion
about oncogenes and tumor
suppressor genes from the
point of view of cell division
control and the
production of more cells
through the action
of these mutations.
And indeed, cancer is a product
of inappropriate cell division.
And the two genes that we
discussed in some detail
regulate this process.
The RAS gene and
the product oncogene
stimulate cell division.
The RB tumor suppressor
gene inhibits cell division.
When we consider the kinds
of mutations that we have
in these genes that regulate
the cell division process--
in the case of the RAS gene,
we find activating mutations.
And in the case of the
tumor suppressor gene RB,
we find inactivating mutations.
RAS is in oncogene.
RB is a tumor suppressor gene.
Activating mutations
in the oncogene.
Inactivating mutations in
the tumor suppressor gene.
But cancer isn't only
about cell division.
It's really about cell number--
inappropriate cell number.
And there's another
important process
to remember in this context.
Apoptosis-- program
cell death, which
I've referred to many times
in many different contexts.
Apoptosis, which
results in dead cells.
And failure to undergo
apoptosis properly
will likewise result in
too many cells, which
again can be cancer causing.
We have genes that
regulate this process.
For example, the P53
gene, which we'll
discuss in some more detail,
positively regulates apoptosis.
And another gene
called BCL-2, which
negatively regulates apoptosis.
Is P53 an oncogene or a
tumor suppressor gene?
Oncogene?
Tumor suppressor gene?
Good.
P53 is a very important
tumor suppressor gene.
It is inactivated in
the context of cancer
because you want to
get rid of apoptosis
as you are developing
cancer cell.
Is BCL-2 an oncogene or
a tumor suppressor gene?
It's an oncogene.
We find gain of function
mutations in BCL-2,
producing more of this
inhibitor of apoptosis
in the context of
cancer to block
apoptosis leading to an
increased number of developing
cancer cells.
OK, so oncogenes and
tumor suppressor genes
can regulate these two
processes differently.
As you can see, inhibitors
in this case, stimulator's
in this case, in the context
of tumor suppressor genes.
All right, a little
bit more about P53,
which is probably the most
important cancer gene of all.
It's mutated in at least
50% of all human tumors.
And P53 is known to function as
a molecular policeman of sorts.
It's sensitive to various
perturbations within the cell.
For example, DNA damage.
DNA damage will feed into
the P53 regulated pathway,
as will a fascinating process,
which is still incompletely
understood, where the cell
can recognize that it's
dividing inappropriately.
Abnormal proliferation-- cells
dividing when it shouldn't.
This gets detected,
and this, too,
can feed into the P53 pathway.
And this leads to an increase in
the levels of the P53 protein.
P53 is a transcription factor.
It regulates the
expression of other genes.
And the genes that it regulates
fall into two broad categories,
some of which cause the cell
to undergo cell cycle arrest.
When the P53
pathway is activated
under certain circumstances, the
cells are instructed to arrest.
During which time,
whatever the damage is
can be fixed before the
cell continues to cycle.
If there's DNA damage, the cell
might arrest, fix the damage,
and then continue on.
In addition, P53
regulates apoptosis,
as I mentioned a few moments
ago, causing the cells to die.
Causing the damaged
cells to die--
and that's good because
dead cells make no tumors.
This is a sacrifice by
the individual cell who
has been damaged, basically
saying, I'm in trouble,
killing itself, and allowing
the organism to survive.
OK, and this is a very important
process in cancer prevention
we now know.
And I'll tell you
some examples of how
we know that momentarily.
OK, so I've introduced you to
a couple of different oncogenes
and a couple of different
tumor suppressor genes.
I want to focus
a little bit more
on the tumor suppressor
genes in one respect.
We touched on this last
time, but very briefly.
Tumor suppressor genes is
sporadically occurring cancers.
And sporadic means
that the individual
has no family history of
that particular cancer type--
sort of a chance event.
And tumor suppressor
genes in sporadic cancers
require two mutational events.
And I described these as hits.
And we typically
do describe them
as hits in the context of tumor
suppressor gene inactivation.
Sometimes it's mutations.
Sometimes it's mutations
coupled with chromosome loss
as the second hit.
But regardless,
two mutations are
necessary to get rid of both
copies of the tumor suppressor
gene.
And I also briefly
introduced you to the fact
that tumor suppressor genes
are often-- not always-- but
for the most part, familial
cancer syndromes, where
the individuals have a
predisposition to developing
a particular type of cancer are
caused by inherited mutations
in tumor suppressor genes.
So one of the hits,
one of the mutations,
is inherited from one parent.
Meaning that every cell
in that person's body
carries one of the
mutations already.
Meaning that only one
hit, one mutation,
is required somatically.
That is in the individual's
own cells in their body.
And this is why
these individuals
are cancer prone,
because they're
one step away from lacking
the tumor suppressor
gene altogether,
whereas in most people
two mutational events are
necessary, and it's rare--
not never, but rare--
to get those two mutations.
And I showed you briefly
this pedigree, which
is a pedigree of
familial retinoblastoma,
where the individuals inherit a
defective copy of the RB gene,
and as such are predisposed
to the development
of this tumor of the eye.
And in fact, they will
develop the tumor typically
in both the eyes, and typically
multiple foci of tumor.
So they inherit a defective
copy of the gene from one parent
and they go on to develop the
disease at high frequency.
When you look at this
pedigree, remembering back
to your lessons in
disease genetics,
this looks like an
autosomal dominant disease.
If you inherit the
disease allele,
you have a very high likelihood
of developing the disease
regardless of who
your other parent was.
It looks like an
autosomal dominant disease
with actually incomplete
penetrance, as we can see here.
And we'll talk more
about this in a second.
An autosomal dominate disease,
but interestingly, we've
been talking about the fact
that the mutations are actually
recessive.
So this seems confusing.
So who can explain it?
How do we have a recessive
mutation at the cellular level
causing what appears to be an
autosomal dominant disease?
Who can answer that question?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Predisposition
is the dominant.
It only needs one mutation.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
Exactly.
You are predisposed.
And there's a very
high likelihood
that in some or in fact,
many of your cells,
this second event will occur.
It's almost guaranteed.
And since it's
almost guaranteed,
if you inherit
just one mutation,
you will develop the
disease, and therefore it
appears to be at the
organismal level--
autosomal dominant-- because
your predisposition nearly
always guarantees that you
will develop the disease even
though the mutations at the
cellular level are recessive.
And so with that in mind, as
we consider a pedigree similar
to the one I just showed
you, where one parent is
heterozygous for the mutation--
the loss of function mutation--
passes that onto the next
generation and beyond,
in this individual, as well
as the other ones shown
with the dark symbols
where a tumor did develop,
what is a necessary
second event?
The loss of the
wild type of allele,
either by a second mutation,
or a chromosome loss event.
And that happens at
very high frequency.
In the case of
retinoblastoma, it typically
happens in a dozen cells
in the developing retina--
leading to an average of
a dozen independent tumors
in those kids.
OK, but now let's think
about this individual
here who did inherit the
defective allele because he
actually passed it on to
his three sons, but he
himself did not
develop retinoblastoma.
How can we explain that?
Why was he spared?
Well, there are two
general explanations.
First, he was incredibly lucky.
Although it's highly likely
that some cell or cells
in the developing
retina will mutate
the normal copy of the gene.
In him, it just didn't happen.
He got lucky.
None of his cells mutated
the normal copy of the gene.
His eyes developed normally.
And after that point,
actually, the cells
are much less
sensitive to mutation,
and therefore after about
three or five years of age,
you typically wouldn't
develop the tumor.
So he might be incredibly lucky.
Or it might be that in him,
because of some other inherited
allele of some other
gene, even if he
were to lose the wild
type alleled of RB gene
it wouldn't matter, because
he's got some other gene that's
functioning maybe in the
place of the RB gene,
leading to him to be protected.
And these two
possibilities exist,
and we have examples of
how both can be important.
OK, final question
on this slide--
what would happen if
an individual inherited
a mutation from both
parents and was therefore
homozygous for a mutation
in a tumor suppressor gene.
What do you think would happen?
The answer was they
would be stillborn
or they wouldn't make
it out of embryogenesis.
And that's usually the case.
And we know that not so much
from the study of people who
are homozygous for
these mutations,
because it's actually quite
rare to find people who are
heterozygous who have children--
so the number of such examples
is few--
but we know it from
knock-out mice.
All of these tumor
suppressor genes
exist within the
mouse genome as well.
And my group and
others have made mice
with mutations in these genes.
And actually we know that, in
fact, for many of the tumor
suppressor genes
that we care about,
like the RB tumor
suppressor gene,
if one creates a
homozygous mutant mouse,
or the APC tumor
suppressor gene, which
is important in colon
cancer prevention,
or the BRCA1 tumor
suppressor gene,
which is important in breast
and ovarian cancer prevention--
in all of these cases,
the embryos don't survive.
And they die at different points
along the way of embryogenesis.
And it's actually not because
they develop lots of cancer
as embryos.
Although, you might have
thought that was true.
They die because these
genes are actually
important in normal development.
They're not there just to
protect against cancer.
They're there because
they play a role
in regulating normal cell
division processes, normal cell
death processes,
normal physiology,
such that when they're missing,
the embryo can't survive.
There's actually one
exception to this.
Well, I shouldn't
say it that way.
There are a few
exceptions to this--
but one notable
exception to this.
And that happens to be the
P53 tumor suppressor gene
that I've introduced you to.
My group and others have made
animals that are mutant for P53
either heterozygous
for the mutation.
What would you expect the
phenotype of these mice to be?
Are they going to be totally
normal mice, do you think?
They are, in fact, cancer prone.
They look like those people
with inherited predisposition
to cancer.
They carry one mutant copy
of a tumor suppressor gene.
And they're one
mutational event away
from lacking the tumor
suppressor gene altogether.
And that happens at some
frequency in their cells.
And the mice will go on to
develop cancer and die early
for that reason.
We cross these mice
together with an expectation
that again, they would
not survive embryogenesis.
But in fact to our
surprise, you can
make a fully P53 null mouse.
And what do you think the
phenotype of that mouse is?
It's very cancer prone.
Because this is a
mouse, that in all
of its cells, this very
important tumor suppressor gene
is lacking.
Normal mice will live about
2 and 1/2 to three years.
These mice will live
about 1 and 1/2 years
and die from cancer
as a consequence.
These mice will live
about four to six months
and die from cancer.
So P53 is actually not
important in normal development.
It is a true tumor
suppressor gene.
It probably evolved
to protect cells
against the kind of damage
that is inflicted on cells
in an individual's lifetime.
And if that damage is
sufficiently great,
the cells are eliminated
or arrest permanently
so they will not develop
into cancer cells.
It's a true tumor suppressor
gene in that case.
OK, so I've told you about
oncogene and tumor suppressor
genes.
We are now entering an era
over the last couple of years
really, where many,
many more cancer
genes are being discovered
through the application
of genomic sequencing in
the context of cancer.
Cancer genomics is all the
rage, including here at MIT,
for example in the
Broad Institute.
And there are many
papers appearing
in the literature
like these looking
at the complexity of the
genome of individual cancers,
like this study out of the
Broad on prostate cancer,
and this study out of the
Sanger Institute in England
on small cell lung cancer.
All the genes or
the entire genomes
of lots of different cancers
are being sequenced and compared
to the normal DNA of
the same individual
to catalog all of
the mutations that
are present within
an individual tumor.
And although there
are differences
depending on the cancer type,
the average cancer genome
actually has 100's and sometimes
thousands of mutations.
Small cell lung cancer, for
example, has tens of thousands
of mutations compared to
normal cells of the lung.
Why?
Because they arise
following years of exposure
to cigarette smoke,
which carries
mutagens that bathe the
DNA in mutation causing
chemicals leading to mutations.
Now, not all of the mutations
that you find in a cancer cell
are relevant to the
cancer phenotype.
In fact, we think
that there's only
amongst all those mutations
that are found that there's
only about 5 to 20 or so
mutations in oncogenes or tumor
suppressor genes.
And we call these
mutations driver mutations.
Driver mutations,
meaning, they actually
are participating in the
development of the tumor,
causing some aspect of
the cancer phenotype.
And the remainder, we
call passenger mutations.
Silent mutations-- mutations
that actually don't do anything
to the cancer
cell, but they just
happened to occur
at the same time,
or in the lifetime
of the cancer cell
when another important
mutation took place.
So that clone of
cells that develops
carries those mutations too,
but they're not actually
contributing to the
cancer phenotype.
So among the hundreds and
thousands of mutations,
some of them really
matter, and some of them
are just going
along for the ride.
It makes the analysis
of the cancer genome
much more complicated,
actually, because it's
hard to tell what's a
passenger, and what's a driver.
But increasingly recognizing
what are the important ones
and focusing our
attention on them.
OK, that's all I'm going to
tell you about cancer genetics.
And I want to now turn my
attention for the last 25
minutes-- and I may
run over a little bit,
so I ask for your patience
if I run over a little bit,
because I do want
to finish this--
to talk about cancer therapy.
Before I make the switch
to cancer therapy,
I want to first introduce the
concept of cancer prevention.
A lot of us work on cancer
genes and cancer genetics
to understand how to
treat cancer better.
But in the future,
hopefully we'll
have many fewer
cancers to treat,
because we'll be
able to prevent them.
If people would
stop smoking, we'd
have 80% fewer lung
cancers to treat.
If you use sunblock and
stay out of the sun,
we'll have fewer skin cancers
to treat and so forth.
Better diet and excess
exercise will prevent a lot
of other types of cancers.
So there are
lifestyle things that
can lower the number of cancers
in the context of cancer
prevention.
There's also ways to prevent
agents from producing cancer
in your body.
And the best example
of that is Gardasil.
Gardasil is an example of
cancer prevention involving
a particular virus--
human papillomavirus--
and specifically,
human papillomaviruses, which
are described as the high risk
type.
Human papillomaviruses or
HPV of the high risk type
can cause cervical cancer.
They are the main reason that
women develop cervical cancer.
And they're responsible
for other types of cancers
as well, including in men.
And what we know is that in
a normal cell of the cervix,
when infected by the
human papilloma virus,
will at some frequency,
and after a period of time,
develop into cervical cancer.
This suggests that the virus--
some genes of the virus--
are changing the cells
behavior in such a way
that it develops into cancer.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I don't
know if you're talking
about our class
or something else,
but it's very rude to talk.
It makes so much noise
during the lecture.
PROFESSOR: Thank you.
So something in the virus
is causing the cells
to divide abnormally
into a tumor.
And this has been
studied at length.
And we now know that
there are two genes, which
are responsible for causing
cervical cells to become cancer
cells--
two genes of the virus
called E6 and E7.
And it's been learned
that these genes in fact
encode proteins that inhibit
cellular proteins that we're
actually quite familiar with.
And we now believe we understand
why the virus causes cancer.
E6 inhibits P53.
And E7 inhibits RB.
So the virus for its own
reasons of viral replication,
takes out these two
tumor suppressor genes.
And as such, the cells
are lacking these two
critical tumor suppressor
genes, and they're
well on their way to becoming
uncontrolled cancer cells.
OK, so that's how HPV high
risk types cause cancer.
And what was developed in the
context of Gardasil is an HPV
vaccine so that individuals
cannot be infected productively
with this class of viruses,
specifically it's a component
vaccine made of recombinant
proteins that are present
in the high risk types of HPV.
As a component
vaccine, this vaccine
does not produce a
replicating virus.
It's just pieces of the virus.
So there's no risk of
a viral infection here.
But an potent
antibody response can
be elicited, including
neutralizing antibodies that
will prevent an
individual from being
infected by the real
thing at a future time.
OK, so that's an example
of cancer prevention,
eliminating an ideological
agent that is responsible.
There aren't many examples of
virus caused cancers in humans.
So this is kind
of a special case.
But HBV-- hepatitis B
virus induced liver cancer
will be another one
before too long.
OK, so now let's talk
about cancer therapy.
I'm going to talk to
you in a few minutes
about some new
cancer therapies that
are based on our
improved knowledge
of the genes in cancer cells.
I'm going to tell you more
about anti HER-2 antibodies.
I'm going to talk to you
more about a small molecule
inhibitor of this kinase.
There are actually
many theorems that
are based on mutations that
we know occur in cancer cells.
There are processes
that I've mentioned
to you, like angiogenesis,
the recruitment of new blood
vessels.
These two have led to
new therapies for cancer
to block that process and
inhibit cancer development.
In the case of tumor
suppressor genes,
individuals are trying
to develop gene therapy
to put the genes back.
If the gene is lost
in a cancer cell,
perhaps you can restore its
function by gene therapy,
and normalize the growth
of the cancer cells.
And although I
won't talk about it,
there's a lot of promise for
immunitherapy for cancer.
Cancer cells acquire
a lot of mutations.
As such, they produce
a lot of antigens.
In theory, your
immune system should
recognize those as foreign
and eliminate the cancer.
But in general, the cancer
wins, the immune system fails.
And we think that there's
ways the cancer actually
inhibits the immune system
from functioning properly.
But that's being
figured out now,
so it's possible that we'll
be able to develop new cancer
therapeutics based
on the immune system.
All right, but before I get
into the cool new stuff,
let me tell you just a little
bit about cancer therapy
more generally--
what we would consider to be
conventional cancer therapy.
The most effective form of
cancer therapy is surgery.
If you can get to the tumor
early before it has spread,
you cut it out, the
person is generally cured.
Another very effective
form of cancer therapy
is radiation therapy.
And this is good because
you can focus the radiation
beam directly on
the cancer cells
and eliminate them by causing
a lot of damage to those cells.
And the third is chemotherapy.
And chemotherapy
is used when you
think that the
cancer has spread,
so radiation can't work because
the cancer cells are somewhere
else--
and you need a drug that can
diffuse throughout the body
and hopefully kill
the cancer cells.
Radiation and many
chemotherapies
act in the same general way.
Adriamycin, which you
will have heard of,
cisplatin, which you
will have heard of--
these are well used
cancer therapeutics--
and many more function by
inducing in the cancer cell DNA
damage.
And the damage can be
sufficiently severe
that the cell will die.
And these therapies
can be effective.
There's another
class of cancer drugs
for which Taxol
is the best known,
which are described
as mitosis inhibitors.
These drugs actually bind
to microtubules, block
the formation of the
microtubular spindle,
and that way prevent
cells from dividing.
And since cancer
cells divide a lot
and you want to
inhibit their division,
these drugs are used
and can be effective.
In fact, they're used because
they were tested and shown
to be effective first in
cell-based studies, where one
looks at the growth or survival
of cells in a Petri dish,
scoring the number of cells
or the percentage of cells
that are alive at
any given time,
or in any given dose of drug
when the concentration of drug
is increasing in
this experiment.
What we find is that for
certain normal cells,
they will survive to a
certain concentration of drug
and then start to die off.
And for certain cancer
cells, the concentration
required to kill them is lower.
And this difference is called
the therapeutic window.
In theory, this looks
good, because it suggests
that the cancer cells are
more sensitive to the drug
than are normal cells.
And that's why some
cancer therapeutics
work for some cancers.
But there are problems.
Some normal cells in your body,
unlike these normal cells,
are very sensitive to the
drug at low concentrations--
the DNA damaging
agents, for example.
This results in side effects.
And I suspect you are all
familiar with the side
effects of cancer chemotherapy.
Your hair falls out.
You get nauseous.
You get anemic.
This is because cells
in your hair follicles,
or your intestines,
or your blood system
are dying at low
concentrations of the drug.
They're actually
dying by apoptosis.
They're actually dying by
P53 dependent apoptosis.
So that's why cancer drugs
cause many bad side effects,
because some cells in your
body are very sensitive
and will kill themselves in
response to low concentrations
of the drug.
The second problem is that some,
in fact not a small percentage,
are very resistant to the
concentrations of the drug--
even high concentrations
of the drug.
And one reason for that
is that many cancer cells
are lacking P53.
I told you that P53 is
mutated in about 50% or more
of human cancers.
I also told you that P53 was
required for cells to respond
to DNA damage and die.
And these cells
lack that protein.
And therefore, are very
resistant to dying.
So many therapeutics
don't work, because
this important
machinery is lacking.
So we have problems
with standard therapies
based on both kinds of issues.
So the goal then,
is to find drugs
that don't cause these
kinds of side effects
and can work even in a P53
deficient cell, which leads us
to developing new
types of therapy.
OK, so I want to introduce
you specifically to two.
And they are probably the best
known and highly effective
actually, great examples
of molecularly targeted
anti-cancer agents.
The first is in the
context of breast cancer.
And the gene in question
here is a gene called HER-2.
In a normal breast cell,
there are two copies
of this HER-2 gene, as there are
in virtually all of your cells.
And those produce
amounts of RNA that
produce amounts of
protein that lead
to the decoration on the
surface of these cells--
the certain number
of receptor molecules
called HER-2, which are a
growth factor receptors.
They bind to specific
growth factors.
And when they are engaged
with their growth factors,
they send a signal
into the cell.
And the product of that signal
is for the cell to proliferate.
And this is necessary in normal
development and in other times.
So this is normal regulation,
normal signaling in response
to a growth factor in the
normal levels of a growth factor
receptor.
30% of breast cancers
carry a mutation
that results in amplification
of the HER-2 gene.
So we don't have two copies
anymore, we've got 10, or 20,
or 50, or 100 amplification.
This is a mechanism by which
all good genes get activated.
Too many genes,
too many proteins.
This cell now has way too
much of that growth factor
receptor on its surface.
And in the presence of the same
concentration of the growth
factor itself, we get a
much stronger signal--
much higher levels
of proliferation.
This also affects the ability
of the cells to survive.
It keeps them alive at times
when they shouldn't be.
Too much proliferation,
too much survival.
Given this situation,
a logical therapeutic
would be something that blocks
the function of this growth
factor receptor.
And what a company called
Genentech discovered
was that they could
make an antibody.
An anti-HER-2 antibody.
And that led to a
drug called Herceptin,
which binds to the
growth factor receptor
and prevents it
from functioning.
And in women who have this
alteration, and only in them,
the drug is actually
highly effective.
In the metastatic
setting, it will
lead to multiple
additional years of life.
But it is actually not
curative in that setting.
Recently, individuals
are being typed
for this mutation at a much
earlier stage in their disease
course.
And when women are
given the drug then,
it's leading to some cures.
So this is a
targeted agent which
is highly effective in the
context of a specific mutation.
And actually only then--
other breast cancer
patients given the same drug
have no benefit whatsoever.
So this is what it looks like.
This is actually
the drug package.
And this is what I
just described to you--
normal cells, cancer cells,
Herceptin antibody binding to
and blocking the function of
this abnormal number of growth
factor receptors.
OK, let me now turn to the
second classic example.
And this comes in the context
of chronic myelogenous
leukemia, which is a
leukemia-- a blood cell tumor.
It's a particular type of blood
cell-- the myeloid lineage
type of white blood cell.
You can diagnose this disease
by looking at blood smears
and you can see that
this is the normal blood
smear with a single of
these myeloid cells.
And here is a cancer
situation where
we've got too many of these
white blood cells circulating.
This is a disease that's been
studied for a very long time.
And it's been discovered
that in the vast majority
of this type of cancer, there is
a specific chromosomal event--
a specific mutation caused by
a particular translocation.
And that translocation
was actually
identified a long time ago
in the city of Philadelphia.
And as such, it's called
the Philadelphia chromosome.
It's the product of a
specific translocation--
chromosome 9, which
has a gene on it
called ABL, which
encodes a protein that
is a kinase involved in
phosphoralating other proteins.
And chromosome 22, which has
another gene called BCR--
chromosome break
events occur here.
Chromosome break
And a translocation
results, which
produces a new chromosome--
the Philadelphia chromosome,
which has the BCR gene and ABL
gene inappropriately
fused to each other.
This produces a fusion gene,
which encodes a fusion protein.
And that fusion protein
is referred to as BCR ABL.
And it was discovered
that the BCR ABL form
had increased kinase activity.
And this resulted in
increased proliferation
within the cells that
carried that translocation.
And so the question was, could
one develop an inhibitor?
An inhibitor that
blocked the kinase?
And this resulted
in the development
of a drug called Gleevec.
Gleevec, which is
highly, highly effective.
This is the idea, here's
the BCR ABL fusion protein.
It binds to ATP, which it needs
to transfer the phosphate group
onto a substrate protein
in this signaling cascade.
The idea is that one could
make a small molecule drug that
could fit into the ATP binding
site very specifically,
and block access of ATP,
therefore shutting off
the kinase.
And if that were possible,
then the cancer cells
would be deprived
of this signal,
and may stop
proliferating, or even die.
That was the idea.
In fact, they were successful
in making a small molecule drug.
And that may surprise
you, because you
might think there are a lot
of kinases in this cell.
They all bind to ATP.
How could you ever find one that
was specific to this kinase?
But in fact, it was possible.
You can make kinase
inhibitors, because not all
the ATP binding
pockets look the same.
And you can therefore
get some specificity.
And when this drug
was used in patients,
it showed remarkable activity.
If we looked at white
blood cell number,
normal individuals would
have a certain low level.
And in case of CML, the
level would be high.
And actually, it
goes higher still
as the disease progresses
through a phase called
blast crisis, where additional
alterations take place
and the cells begin to
divide even more abnormally.
In this context, however,
if you give the drug
Gleevec, in the vast
majority of patients,
the numbers drop precipitously.
And the drug is extremely well
tolerated-- has almost no side
effects.
The patients take the pill
with their orange juice
in the morning every day,
keeping their cancer cells
at bay, leading to what is
called clinical remission.
Clinical remission-- the
disease has gone into remission.
And it can stay in remission
for a very long time.
And it's sometimes curative.
But sometimes the
disease cells come back.
And this is a phase
we call relapse.
And even though the drug is
present throughout this disease
course, the tumor cells
are dividing again.
Can anybody tell me why?
Mutation.
The cancer cells have
acquired additional mutations,
specifically within DCR ABL.
If we imagine DCR ABL,
it can bind to Gleevec,
and be shut off.
At some frequency,
however, mutations
can occur, which change the
active site in such a way
that Gleevec can no longer bind.
And this is still
an active kinase.
So now the cells
begin to divide again.
So the question now is
what can you do about it?
And the answer is, you
can make a new drug.
And this has actually
been done successfully.
A new drug that can
bind specifically
to the mutant form
of ABL kinase.
And there's a drug called
SPRYCEL, which is now also
FDA approved for the treatment
of drug resistant forms of CML.
So before you run away, this
is what I've just told you,
here's ABL kinase.
This is where the drug binds.
This is the structure
of the drug.
But at some frequency,
mutations occur
within that ATP binding site.
And different mutations will
do this, as shown down here.
And those mutations will
block the access of the drug.
And the good news
is that one could
make new drugs
that will overcome
that form of resistance.
So this is a good news,
bad news, good news story.
We'll stop there.